I'm sure everything was wrong Everything
I've done so far has been
wrong Raphtalia I don't have the right to
be by your side
Ugh
you're not wrong
I met you  Without it, no one would believe me and I would have escaped from this world.
[Music]
I'm here because
you believed in me at that time
.  Raphtalia, who was so small, became
the hero of the shield Yes, she became so cool after working under it You
came to save us, so
look at
those girls
You protected them Obun-san, don't
cry anymore Hero of the
shield  Because I was able to meet ko
Hana-chan, I'm sure she'll be happy too
From now on, we'll protect you I wo
n't let you or anyone else have this kind of feeling
That's why we've fought together
The hero of the shield,
no me
[music]
I'm envious of you,
don't you
?